a
ihren letzten mädchen geschrieben dass
sich rum kommen soll
weil bei ihren die wir uns zu hause sein
[Musik]
also bin ich zu ihr gefahren und es war
niemand zu hause
und damit herzlich willkommen wie heute
zu einer neuen episode take you stayed
10 euro dass ich mich wieder verlieben
werde
[Musik]
a
warum seid ihr noch dran
[Musik]
komme 1
millionen
laux
[Musik]
millionen
mikes
habe ich irgendwas verpasst weiß nicht
ob ich mein lachen soll aber was nie
wieder
[Musik]
die knacken
bauer
[Musik]
was hat diese straße mit mir gemeinsam
kein verkehr
hier seht ihr im volk
wir fahren
[Musik]
das wasser läuft gerade frauen vor die
magische marke
[Musik]
[Applaus]
egal
der junge hat arbeit komplett
durchgespielt
jetzt guck mal
woher woher du bist still und ich
hierauf macht
[Musik]
als auch schon
warum
bekomme ich sowas auf meiner homepage
[Musik]
das erste video was mich heute wirklich
zum lachen bringt auch gut ist auch gut
wir sind auf gutem weg
[Musik]
wir sind also wir haben hier wirklich
gerade kreativen content
[Applaus]
dann kommt die deutsche
ost und einfach wieder völlig rein
machen abschuss bühne was hat der
busfahrer
[Musik]
dann kannst du mir vielleicht zeigen wir
dass rückwärts funktioniert es gut dass
auch ist auch sehr gut wie sie
verfolgungsjagd es zu gehen
a
ist das eine spinne gewesen hatte es
kurz davor sich den wohn zuschnappen
erschafft es hunter zu entkommen er hat
schon sehr lange nichts mehr gegessen
alleine hier weiter
[Musik]
wow
57.000 laux kann man das rückgängig
machen
[Musik]
m
schiff bisschen ja
jedes mal
nicht auf tipptopp in sich was mit mir
ja
mach das mal nicht mehr baby co
[Musik]
ich habe sehr gute laune t acht minuten
statt vier minuten ziehen lassen
heute abend eskaliert so richtig
[Musik]
perfekt
also ich würde ich auch in ugly nehmen
den direktor mit irgendwelchen psycho
zulegten
[Musik]
winterstein minuten gebe ich euch bomber
zwei minuten später gleiten wie ein
staubsauger
denn es wird youtube bald nicht mehr
läuft alter werde ich einmal ein
staubsauger ja
ja
bevor das
erschwert würde ich das heute wieder an
der stelle auch beenden wenn euch die
top 10 mit mir luca gefallen wenn wir
noch sonstiger
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann abonniert
main kanal
klocke damit der neue videos nicht
verpasst
[Musik]